[Music]
peace be with you welcome to the d
show another week another episode
exciting exciting some very great topics
now imagine this you're at the
university
and now the professor you're taking the
philosophy class and he writes on the
ward there is no god
and now you start debating this subject
but you're one who believes
in the creator because it's natural but
you don't believe in all these man-made
religions but you believe in the true
way of life that's sent from the creator
how do you tackle this or now you're
just having a nice conversation and a
person says look i believe in science
it's not like you know islam is calling
you to turn off your brain not to think
because we know the quran is a book that
proves it's from the creator
but how now do you deal with this new
atheism and the challenges that are
facing us
well my next guest is going to help us
when we come back here in the
show don't go anywhere
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
how are you shake how are you doing how
are you doing brother good good thank
you for being with us
here on the dean show thank you for
inviting me time is short so we get
right into it you heard me open up the
show now is this something that
uh you've uh been approached with maybe
one of the students said look i was in
my
university class and the professor wrote
on the wall there is no god
yes you know atheism is something which
is very widespread these days and
especially intellectual atheism you know
where
um the idea which is being spread is
generally religions and in particular in
particular islam and muslims
they are not intellectual they are not
academic and this whole idea of
belief in god is outdated it's something
which doesn't fit with the modern times
because science has disproved god and
especially when students go in an
academic environment in universities
even in high schools this is on the rise
um they find that there are increasingly
a greater number of scientists
uh who are teaching who are the
professors they don't believe in god
and a lot of the young minds they get
very influenced by these people that you
know if this person has a phd
from you know one of the ivy leagues or
one of the top schools and he's so
intelligent he's
so smart how come he doesn't believe in
god so this really gets to some people
and it's very important that we
understand some of the very basics of it
like
atheism appeals to reason
and we can show and modern science has
shown
that by appealing to reason at the same
time there are some very strong and
convincing arguments
against atheism and for theism in other
words
for the for the for the belief and
existence of god
and i'm just talking about at that level
not even you know the elements of tahith
and other elements
now now tell us look the people are
seeing this basketball you know we know
that the uh we're from here in chicago
and uh the the the bulls are in the
playoffs i believe right are you a bulls
fan right
i don't watch my sport i don't watch
much but people are thinking why do they
have
a a little ball but almost like a mini
basketball yeah on the dean shaw are we
going to be talking about the
bulls or uh i'll i'll explain a concept
of physics of cosmology using this ball
okay so we're going to get to that later
yes now tell us you said something
uh reasonable but when we look at it it
seems like something so
irrational because how can some
something come from nothing
right so how can someone claim that i
understand that
in a lot of these irrational religions
that are man-made and when you compare
it to islam it just makes sense so do
you think a lot of these professors they
became
agnostic atheists because of all the
man-made religions
that just don't make sense that's an
excellent point that's one of the
reasons why some of them lose their
faith is because
when you know whatever they really
believe system is it just doesn't make
sense
so that's one aspect of it but then they
also discredit islam because they see
islam is also a theistic religion it's a
religion which
talks about belief in god that's what it
is based on on a single one
supreme being and in their mind they
believe that
there is a scientific explanation for
everything
why do we need belief in god that's how
that's how they appeal to reason
and they don't even explore the
evidences for islam
so so we need to kind of meet them where
they are
and show them how reason does not go
against
uh belief in god and how we have some
very strong reasons and the one which i
want to
in particular talk about is known as the
fine tuning argument
it's from modern cosmology it's very
well studied uh and in particular it has
been developed over the last few hundred
years based on cosmology based on our
findings of the universe
and the beginnings of the universe and
how the universe is expanding and how
the universe is headed towards uh
towards
some end and some gold so so that's what
you're going to give us when we come
back from the break
you're going to break it down how
someone can go ahead and talk to an
intellectual academically
and give some of these i'll throw some
pointers in there some pointers in there
you've heard it here on the dean's show
tackling the new car
the new it's called the new atheism the
new enthusiasm don't worry about it we
got it here on a dean show
don't go anywhere the apple of macintosh
dazzled the world it was invented by
steve jobs
but who invented the apple repeat
the stethoscope it was invented by the
french physician renee linneck
in 1818 but who created the ear
in which we hear everything
the calculator was invented by the
frenchman blase pascal
in 1639 who created the human brain
which equals one million of advanced
calculators working
at the same time the electric light bulb
which we turn to light in a room
it was invented by thomas edison in 1879
so who created the self-illuminating sun
which radiates the whole world
[Music]
the plane it was invented by wilbur
wright in 1903
but who invented the systems in birds
that enable them to fly long distances
[Music]
he is allah the creator of
everything
look for him you will find him
newly allah.com
[Music]
please subscribe to the show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the dean show
by making a donation
in the link below
[Music]
back here on the dean's show and like i
said don't worry about it
we got it here on the dean show with my
guest
you're going to give some refutations
some arguments
please take it away okay so what we have
is basically what is known as the
fine-tuning argument
this is based on some of the ancient
arguments which philosophers used to
give and which were adopted by several
religions
for the existence of god uh in the
simplest terms it's known as the design
argument the argument by design
in which you know a person doesn't have
to know a lot of science a person
doesn't have to know a lot of
mathematics
they definitely don't need to be a
cosmologist they're about 1 000 in the
world today
all they need to do is look at the sun
the moon and the stars
and say that they cannot be here without
i mean all of these things they show a
grand design
the way the sun is the way the moon is
and the precision with which they rotate
and the precision with which they uh you
know the day comes and the seasons come
there is a design to everything and they
say that if there is a design
there must be a designer so this is the
simplified version of the argument
but now when we come to science we see
that uh all the
everything which takes place and you
know all our modern technology is based
on that science
for example the cameras uh the cars our
computers our gadgets
uh rockets they are all based on for
example uh uh
statistical mechanics they are all based
on electromagnetics they are all based
on classical mechanics
quantum mechanics theory of relativity
so there are about four or five
different branches of
of science in particular of physics and
there are some fundamental equations
mathematical formulas which describe
all of what we see in the nature what we
observe
and what we can test in the lab as well
as all the technology which we see
it's all based on some of these
fundamentals of science
which can be defined by some equations
so there are
three aspects over here of what is
called as the fine-tuning argument
the first is that there are actually
laws of nature which describe pretty
much everything
including the very beginning of universe
the very immediately begin beginning of
universe and that's we will talk about
this ball
shortly the second aspect is
that outside of these equations and if
somebody doesn't know what an equation
is think of
think of it like this 4x is equal to y
square
basic algebra of course these equations
are way more complicated
but that's an equation example of an
equation of a mathematical equation
uh the number four is known as a
constant in this equation
it's a number that's all it doesn't
change it's not a variable
just like this there are certain
constants in nature
for example the speed of light it
doesn't matter if you are on the sun the
moon
or if you're in a different galaxy or if
you're anywhere in the universe the
speed
of light is a constant it stays the same
the same thing goes for uh subatomic
particles
the ratio of the electron and the proton
mass the charges so there are certain
things like this
that are constants that are fixed that
don't depend on anything
and there is no reason why they are what
they are here's the important thing
there is no reason why they are what
they are
they are fixed that's the second aspect
and i'll talk about the fine tuning i
still didn't get there
there is a third aspect which is what is
known as the initial conditions so when
the universe started
uh 15 to 20 billion years ago that's the
modern estimate
there were certain conditions that were
set
in the beginning okay so for example
this ball is at a certain distance from
the table it has a certain weight so
these are the initial conditions it's
not moving right now
right but these are sort of the initial
conditions as to where it is
and why it is right now so there are
certain conditions which describe it
the ball doesn't have to be over here it
could be down here it could be a bigger
ball right so these certain
initial conditions are also arbitrary
there is no reason why they are what
they are okay
so we have two things over here uh the
initial conditions and the constants of
nature
that seem to be very
finely tuned okay
for life to exist in the universe that's
profound yes
in other words in other words if
some of these constants were slightly
different very slightly different
we would not be here there would be no
intelligent
life that could exist yes
this is a very simple explanation of
fine tuning
okay well what are these numbers that we
are talking about how
improbable how next to impossible
is it for life to exist because of these
numbers
i'll give you uh the one of the most
extreme examples
in modern cosmology of of a constant
it's known as the penrose number
what is it don't worry about it it's
named after a
british cosmologist whose name is roger
penrose he's a life he's
one of the smartest you know
cosmologists out there right now
he figured out some equations and he
said that in the beginning of the
universe
there is something called in physics
entropy which means it's a measure of
disorder
low entropy means that it every particle
has to be precisely at the same point
i'll end with the with the talk of
entropy uh
high entropy means very disordered you
know like you walk into a room of a kid
or a teenager and you see how everything
is out of place
that's high entropy you walk into a very
organized room that's low entropy
so in the beginning of the universe you
can this is a very rough
i'm talking i'm simplifying things and
taking liberties over here so please
understand that right
that in the beginning when universe
started the big bang as they call it
started
this is kind of what the universe was
and the
measure of disorder was very small
how small 10 to the power 10 to the
power 123
that means 10 to the power
10 and that 10 is followed by 123 zeros
what how big is this number our minds
can't even grasp it i'll give a few
examples shortly
what is this number so we cover design
yes cover design
fine tuning now the three types of fine
tuning yes the laws of physics
the constants of nature and the initial
conditions when the universe started i
mean this is profound i mean these are
some great examples we're gonna get into
some more
where we left off don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the d
show follow us on our official facebook
and twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]
back here on the dean show we're
tackling the new atheism
shay go ahead and take it away we were
talking about the third
category of the fine tuning yes please
okay
so as i was explaining is that this uh
ball has to be every particle in it has
to be in
almost a precise place and the number
which i gave the number which roger
penrose calculated is 10 to the power 10
to the power 123.
uh 10 to the power 123 means 10 repeated
after that there is 123 zeros
and then you raise 10 to that number
you know this number how big is this
number i want to give
an example of a much smaller number i'll
give two examples
imagine that you're in one corner of the
universe and you throw a dart
the chances of that dart hitting a penny
on the other end of the universe that
number is
way bigger it's almost 10 to the power
30. i'll give another example can you
imagine like
what is the likelihood of you throwing a
dart from one end of the universe
and it hitting a penny on the other end
of the universe so you're saying that's
more likely than all of this coming by
chance
way more likely just the penrose number
yeah just depending on
this is amazing let me give you another
example a billion pencils
please say that how many a billion a
billion pencils you have this glass
surface right
what are the chances of a billion
pencils standing on their edge
at the same time simultaneously without
falling down on a smooth glass surface
that's 10 to the power 60 only
meaning 10 and there are 60 zeros after
that
it's again a very big number compared to
this
one number of uh compared to this one
number of 10 to the power 10 to the
power 123 of roger penrose's number
let me give another illustration over
here so what i'm saying these two
numbers are
are like insignificant so i gave you two
examples something which is so
mind-boggling but they are insignificant
now here is the here is the here is the
here is the punch line
imagine that you have these different
dials
okay and you can change the roger the
penrose number you can change the speed
of light you can change the
gravitational force you can change the
electronic force the weak electric force
the
strong electric force nuclear forces you
can adjust all these different forces
which are the constants of nature and
the initial conditions
okay and then you have like a screen
which will give you like a preview
if you change this a little bit over
here how will the universe move on how
will it evolve
and if you change this dial a little bit
what will happen
here is the thing these values these
dials have been set so precisely
so precisely that is almost impossible
to imagine it is unreasonable
that's the word it is unreasonable to
imagine
that it happened by chance
that somebody set these dials to their
very precise numbers and i gave a few
examples of how precise those numbers
have to be
just by chance in order for they to be
life
in order for their for life to exist in
the universe
this is uh it's it's an unreasonable
it's unreasonable to say
that these numbers were there just by
chance it's unreasonable
now have you presented this have you sat
down with an academic with a a scholar
and let's say
any field of chemistry biology from the
university have you presented these
arguments
these these facts are well known they
are well studied by cosmologists
they are they are very well studied by
cosmos so how could someone after
they hear something like continue on
denying the supreme being the creator of
all that exists
that's an excellent question okay if the
evidence is so clear how can a person
deny
they they come up with some very
irrational
they come with very irrational and
unreasonable answers but
i thought you said they're rational
they're reasonable they are reasonable
when it comes to science but when it
comes to belief in god they become
uh irrational because you see belief in
god comes with responsibility
and they don't like that that's the key
responsibility it comes with like you
have to worship allah
now now we're getting somewhere we guess
we can see the motive behind this yes
um and some of them have actually you
know changed there are some people that
change many do
many of them do so some of these people
who have come up with some of these
numbers and others they are theists they
are believers and they say
it's uh it's it's next to impossible to
deny the existence of god
there are people uh quite a few
professors some of them are nobel
laureates
who hold this belief so some of the
reasons they come up with is they say
hey this is pure chance
it's just chance that's all what it is
so the question we can ask them is this
like let's say that you're put in front
of a firing squad
right and there are 100 trained
shooters with loaded guns who and their
job is to shoot at you
and the numbers by the way over here are
very small compared to the numbers we
are talking about
and they are all ordered to shoot you
they all direct
your guns their guns at you and they
shoot and they all miss
they all miss and you say you know what
they missed that's all that there is to
it there is no explanation
but this is where we come and we say you
know what there
has to be an explanation because the
event is so
magnanimous that it deserves an
explanation
you cannot just say it just is and move
on
yes but that's basically what they say
the other uh explanation which is given
by some of them or a cop-out or a way
out
is they say that the laws of physics and
mathematics created it
well that's giving creative power to
laws which we
understand which we have deduced which
we have studied
they are predictive not creative so
these laws we can use to predict what
will happen
so in other words there are certain
equations in physics newton's laws from
which i can base and say that you know
this ball if it will drop with what
velocity it will hit the ground so on
and so forth but the law itself did not
create the ball
the law itself did not create gravity
there has to be a creator for
these laws and the phenomenon and the
universe which obeys these laws
then they come up with a third answer as
well
it's also very disingenuous it's uh what
they say is that you know what
we are and this requires actually a
greater explanation but at least i will
mention it for the sake of
you know just for completeness they say
that
our universe is not the only universe
we are one part of a multiverse well why
do they come up with multiverse why
where does this idea even come from so
what this is that you know what
we are basically like the winners of a
cosmic lottery
right let's say that there is one in 10
million chance but someone wins the
lottery
but there is a one in 10 million chance
but someone wins the lottery so think of
it like there is some sort of a universe
generating machine
which is pumping out universes balls
every ball every ball is a universe
we just happen to be the ball which had
the right conditions
and we developed to come back and say
you know what
this is amazing there is life over here
do you want me to give you a very simple
answer to this please go ahead
here is the problem there are several
problems one major problem
we are in this ball right this is our
universe we are making an assumption
over here and this is very unscientific
that there are all these other
multiverses
next to next to infinite universes
which they call multiverse in which life
does not exist
but by definition they cannot be studied
scientifically
we cannot even study them we cannot even
ever by definition
know whether they exist or they don't
exist
and that's very unscientific yes so to
disprove god
they come up with these uh or to not
accept god they come up with these
uh very unreasonable explanations
here i'll give another thing there is
actually a theorem in cosmology which
says
even subhanallah this is amazing
even if there was a multiverse
even if there was a multiverse it must
have a beginning yes even if there were
multiple infinite number of multiple
universes
there must be a beginning to them
so there is so heads or tails
fine-tuning winds heads or tails
god wins allah wins you cannot escape
this
clear evidence which is out there unless
you become unscientific and unreasonable
unreasonable definitely thank you very
much for helping us tackle this topic
i know the time was short but hopefully
you guys you got some very good points
out there for the sincere person
you got to be sincere absolutely seeking
the truth hopefully this will resonate
and we'll see you next time in charlotte
thank you so much thank you very much
thank you and thank you for watching the
d show now the same way if you're
playing ball
and the person asks you where'd that
ball come from you wouldn't just say
from nothing
or if you were on the beach and you were
just
playing some beach volleyball and you
went on the sand and you saw like what's
this and you ended up seeing an iphone
what is it six
and you blew off the sand and you picked
it up you wouldn't just think it came
from nothing would you
no you wouldn't silly now that's the
thing that we have to
really ponder over these are things that
are just evident self-evident and it's
in our very nature to believe
but it goes against our nature to
believe
in a lot of these man-made religions
that start to worship a stick of stone
the sun the moon
so definitely we say what the atheist
says in a sense when we declare that
there's nothing worthy worship there's
no god
except the one true god the creator of
all that exists so jesus is not god nor
did he ever claim to be god
muhammad is not god none of the creation
is god
except the one who created creation and
that makes sense
look into it some more watch us here on
the dean's show subscribe if you haven't
already
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the show by
making a donation in the link below